good afternoon my name is Thomas Weber
I'm happy to present you my presentation
which I'm gonna do this together with my
son to be as Weber who just started to
work with Mathematica that helped me in
this whole presentation a few words of
my myself I'm a mathematic a user from
version 1.2 I used to make my PhD during
the time of a PhD PhD for studying
economics and I'm working since I
finished my PhD the banking industry and
we do all kind of modeling quantitative
questions and very often Mathematica is
the background for doing kind of and it
is in this environment so Bob is mainly
pricing derivatives or risk management
and they used to have a some employees
everybody had to know Mathematica but we
were not selling mathematical skills
tried that are not able to sell in
Germany at least where we come from
Mathematica skills you have to sell
solutions and we found that using
Mathematica we are very capable of doing
some kind of solutions well companies
had big problems like for example we
were consulting one of the major banks
in Germany for the first time and they
will try to do belly at risk was a
Mathematica notebook where we developed
the first risk calculation same when we
did calculation of credit exposure when
you try to find out what you can lose in
the future and you have to simulate surf
and that was also done in Mathematica so
we like to do prototyping Mathematica we
always built throwaway prototypes we
only had one occasion in over the 20
years I'm working in this industry where
actually won Mathematica application got
into production
for half a year then it got thrown out
because IT department said no it's
strange software that doesn't fit in our
architecture it was run out which was
nice for us because we first made the
prototype in there was a smaller project
estimation of the term structure we all
have done four weeks about them that do
it well to everybody were happy then we
had the chance to do the right
implementation in C++ which took it a
year so out of this small project we had
a big project putting this into the
software so okay so much to my person so
I like to do I'm interested in biking
it's fun to ride my bicycle and there is
this is now some hobby work but from
this set up how we do that I think it's
very comparable how we work in banks so
we have a lot of data we have we have to
find a model to describe this data or
work with this data and see and we don't
know at the end if this works out or it
doesn't work out if you have to improve
our maliki how this right so it's it
I think this setup is very similar to
the way we work in banks and from that
point it might be also be interesting if
you're not so much in bike riding
if you just think want to know how we
use Mathematica in practice okay and I'm
not used to this present a tur soft we
always seems to be the traditional plug
okay
what's the setup there to buy grease
from magic from Belgic down to grease
and the challenge is rather simple be as
fast as possible starting bare cheeks
together we start all together or
everybody starts together and you have
to go to crease as fast as possible very
simple setup the only thing you have to
do you have to meet
certain checkpoints so you have to go
here the Alps then over the ABS to
Slovenia then from sylvania to Poland
and then you can go on down to Creek so
it's a long distance and what's unique
about that is that there's no predefined
route so one of the challenging but you
get the tour or that it needs to
checkpoints in November and I promise
you you're busy until the start of the
race to find out what's okay now that
was a challenge and when you start out
you well what do you do you go to the
available software like whatever and try
it out and find drive the best with
first of all most of the routes are very
similar but fine - yeah but that's at
least the moment when you think about
law they have this wonderful tool one
that Mathematica where we can maybe do
some kind of analysis it's not a simple
problem because the data is not very
good structure but well let's try to see
how far we get
okay what's also important if you do
this kind of ride and this is a picture
from the last year's right how do you
start here and you end up here do you
see how everybody goes the course over
Europe and everybody is equipped with
the tracker which sends your position to
satellite
let's get captured and you can see them
on the webpage actually you can download
if you know where it is you can download
this data so actually we have collected
all the data from although this race yes
here is the previous race to find out
how which kind of true they did and how
they yeah how fast they where are they
and and everything so we have a
situation where we do have a lot of data
available
and I want to ensure you just to give
you an idea cannot see you yeah idea how
this looks like
we look at the second stage where we
start in the Alps and go to the two over
here to the target in Sylvania and I
just picked four riders and you see them
with the different colors and now it
gives we have a night situation
everybody goes to sleep that's kind of
when we have the triangle then you see
the one guy the American guy he really
gets up one o'clock in the morning to
start and we go all here well almost
everybody on the same route they're not
so much routes to the Alps but then
happens something in strange you look at
this guy he's from England it was half
the special way and he's much faster
than I well then we so what happened
here he did the she's the better route
so my preparation of half a year work on
preparation my didn't find I was not
happy about that and we continue to work
on that but first of all some other
things we have to in mathematical
directions which allows you to travel
from one place to find a route for one
place to another place great because
this is Mathematica there's a lot of you
can use it in Mathematica in this
environment so great but the problem is
if you look at the data which it
connects you see it's just a straight
line more or less of the speeds it
doesn't take into account if you go and
mountain I'll go down so not
insufficient a very insufficient and
what I don't like about this at all is
there's nothing you can play around with
so it's not sufficient to do really
planning that's the kind of two of a
fine so that's a tyre to the other one
guy used
for example and this is the one provided
by Mathematica so you just find
something about but it doesn't take into
account any what's the problem so what
do you do well with your own so we
started out building our own and to do
that we retrieve data from open Street
Market open street data open street map
and ok that's in German now at the
moment but you have this and there's a
nice notebook about how to do that where
we got inspired from looking at that and
you can download data for the region's
one of the problem is well here we show
you how you can do find out what kind of
region you want to download if you
download that that's megabyte of theta
which we huge about later and because in
this data is every everything is in this
data you do see it almost every building
so when I saw this presentation this
morning where he randomly did some
locations and to find out how their
storm effects that's all data available
the only problem is it's big and it's
hardly accessible my Mathematica crashed
if I try to read it in ok we did it this
anyway and started to build the network
the data consists of nodes where is in
relations we are interested interested
in the base and we need the notes
because they are connected by ways and
we can just extract that from the data
and this works if you reduce your
dataset very much ok so that's what we
have done here so you see the nodes at
the base of the nodes how they look like
you have K position and then you can
build crafts out of that and this is a
graph between the two Oh from Syrian to
Oh mark the one where you have seen the
one guy giving other directions and we
were happy coming up with this beautiful
picture hope you enjoy I do
the problem is did work what we are not
really were able well as missing
basically is to wait the to us we are
taking so we have want to get the hills
in so that's a challenge and the data is
not available in OpenStreetMap so it's a
shortcut but we really own that so we
didn't get another problem we wanted
really able to work with this calves of
this size in Mathematica just too big
and another issue is that the numbering
has to be in a certain way that you can
really work with that if you just take
the notes it doesn't work so what do
next as I said not an unusual situation
in a project in a bank because you
always run into some area and it doesn't
know a street and you have to jump out
but that's help actually there's a in
github there is a project which allows
you to do open street routing routing on
top of open street map which is actually
used by one of this is joint venture if
you want to name it like that from one
of the main provider of routing engines
so wonderful and it's in C++ and that's
a situation a place the banks where they
always are quite happy fair something to
C++ because we are able to integrate
something in C++ with in Mathematica
within minutes by well we have built
work with Mathematica for 20 years we
have built up the wrapper for the math
link and we have for building
environment whether we can just know or
let's say this is the class we wanting
to create and then we do have it
so actually we most of have it available
and we asked them and actually they did
provide us tools
also the route from the English guy here
then we I mean maybe down so what we
have done here a little bit
actually you can know downtown you can
up put this up as a local server you can
download compile it have it available as
a local server which is also very
comfortable because allows you to do
some kind of stuff like that
trains in Germany where you don't have
access to the Internet so you can work
with that and then you get back the the
boy points and stuff like that and you
can just read it in in Mathematica with
Jason found you have the PD available so
it's a really convenient way this way to
have it as a server but we also
integrate it it's the simplest possible
team in Mathematica so that we can
really working details find out how this
works and as I said does shows you and
yeah so here at least you see the root
and you see Mathematica didn't use it
because using the Gale elevation data
from Mathematica we colored where the
mountains are so here there's a mountain
that's a reason you say Kuwait that's
region so if you're bad climb bar then
take the other Road but if you're good
climb but then it's shorter route and
actually faster route depending on your
ending abilities what we so but there's
more - it's what we like here with this
open Street routing machine is that you
can define all details how for example
surface affects your speed so there's a
ant
so we can overwrite this file simply and
then we can try to find out how we might
change the settings to see that we yeah
try to get the setting alright
okay just here that's what we made
available
that's our executable based on math link
and we all have this functionality now
available to do further planning and
that's as I said in our environment
simpler thing to do okay so in the next
step and the idea or what we wanted to
do is we wanted to estimate and analyze
the data we collected from previous
tracks and also simulate and new bike
right make a simulation of a bike ride
on a new track for this we have to take
a deeper look into the model of bike
riding where on one side the input is to
power the bike rider gifts into the
bicycle and on the outside the output is
to speed so from speed to power their
free main forces which come in is to
winter assistance we have to overcome
the rolling resistance and the pull of
gravity and some smaller ones like the
acceleration from one speed to another
or the mechanical loss and because we
have not that much time I will rush a
little bit on this and we were able to
come up with formula for getting from
the speed to the power and which is
pretty helpful if you have no
measurement tool on your bike for
getting you the use power but you can
easily collect the speed so for analyzes
to the previous tricks just will help us
a lot and on the other side from power
to speed we will use later on to
simulate a bike ride on new bike on new
tracks because M it's the same equation
just solve for the velocity so we can
put in account
the different grades of the roads and
we're able to play a lot with this
formula this is how we collect it to
data on the previous tricks there the
bicycle computer on the bike it's
collecting the data during the right and
later upload it to the Strava a website
which is like facebook for sports where
a lot of people are uploading the data
and we can download it pretty easily and
import it to Mathematica provided API
and there are two different kinds of
data files the activity data file which
is like an overview of Earth often too
often an activity which has the total
distance the total moving time as well
as in a rough map of the two tool which
was done which is compressed but after
we can decode it you can show it
Geographics command so in this example
this is the tool which was done and but
for pre analytics we want to have this
second type of data file which is for
every tool which is called stream and it
gives for every measured data point the
time stamp the distance the velocity and
the great of this of of the of this
certain point and then we can plot it
and see like the profile from the tool
which was done the different speeds the
different speeds and using our our power
function we then can see how much how
much power was put in the bicycle during
the right and it's in this example it
just it is too long yeah around 150
kilometers it was around 115 yeah
there's some measurement mistakes you
see so it goes sometimes up to 400 but
but in yeah
the average 115 so so now we wanted to
see how good our function our model for
bike riding is to simulate for
simulation and for that we assume that
the power we put in is constant and then
we have to find out two testimony our
model we're using the data of a lot of
like in this example
82 us to find for every specific grade a
specific velocity which I plotted here
and then we fit a function for it to get
to lose all the noise because you can
see if sometimes you stop sometimes you
break and yeah so much mistakes but it's
pretty good and if we use our our speed
function by the crate and plot it to
this as well then so yeah it worked
before you can see that it's pretty
close that our function is pretty close
to the fitted function and we can play a
little bit with the constant parameters
like the the power you put in or the
height of the of the biker or the
temperature and in the end yeah
so if you go and download our notebook
you will see that we can simulate our
bike rider
it's been functional yeah then you can
see that yeah we can simulate pretty
well with our speed function how the
bike rider will drive compared to how he
actually drove on the tracks we did come
to conclusion yeah okay we help have
hope to show you how similar ated our
model compares to the real right on the
profile between Cillian and ham Agora
the area we're looking at and well we
find that when we are optimistic we get
some kind of fits it does it does work
but the stupid rider slab sleeps in
between so you see it's very close until
he goes to sleep
then he's lagging it about the period he
slept so that's the reason we have so
that's in the data and that's correct
data but yeah we have to do more data
cleaning more trying to control for more
variables so far and what's the next
thing we want to do is yeah what we
really like is the amount of data we
have an Open Street Map surfaces we see
we can measure the Angel of curves so
which we come to occur if we can really
see what kind of if we have to break
down or not and there's plenty of data
and it's accessible the huge sides makes
it more problematic but there's an
interface where we can for example open
over the past happy which we mentioned
shortly where you can really ask for
details on there certain things and with
the open source mangum c++ whatever we
which allows you to work with the
OpenStreetMap data in detail and make
that's really powerful so we want to use
more data because we get fascinated
about data we have available and
can do with that and yeah we have to
work more that because in our model at
the moment we do not really take care
that we might go down a hill and then go
in the flat and that's the reason we
have 4x in we'll see these high values
in there on the flat area because we
came down and hill so we do have a
highly autocorrelation of data we didn't
account for that either so there's a lot
of things we have to further work with
the data and yeah that's what we plan to
do in this environment
thank you Matt
[Applause]